please little government prime minister
ordering an inquiry into the green seal
scandal was supposed to find answers
but the questions keep coming questions
to the prime minister
the green seal scandal is just the tip
of the iceberg
dodgy contracts privileged access
jobs for their mates this is the return
of tory sleaze
mr speaker it's now so ingrained in this
conservative government
we don't need another conservative party
appointee
marking their own homework the prime
minister conceding he is concerned
i uh indeed share the widespread concern
about some of the stuff that we're
reading at the moment mr speaker and i i
know that the cabinet secretary
shares my concern as well i do think it
is a
a good idea in principle that
uh top civil servants should be able to
engage with
uh with business and should have
experience of the private sector
uh when i look at uh the uh accounts i'm
reading today it's not clear that those
boundaries were uh have been properly
understood
eyes to the right 260
this afternoon mps rejected a labour
attempt to hold a parliamentary probe
but the treasury select committee
decided to hold one anyway
and a second committee may do the same
the problem is
that the current lobbying rules are not
fit for purpose
because there are barely any lobbying
rules the green cell affair is deeply
disappointing not least for those who
admire the former prime minister
and his work but we should now be
focused on learning lessons from this
downing street and whitehall seem at
first glance impenetrable
impossible to access but it's easy if
you know the right people
especially for those who used to work
here
the scandal which has damaged the
reputations of david cameron lex
greenstall and some former senior civil
servants
is getting closer to boris johnson and
this door by the day
the prime minister says he has never had
any contact with david cameron about
green sill
but two of his cabinet ministers have
rishi sunak and matt hancock
as have two junior treasury ministers
and boris johnson's
senior special adviser greensell capital
had meetings with the chief executive of
the nhs in england
a series of other nhs figures plus the
two most senior civil servants
in the treasury
labour are attempting to compare this
scandal to the conservative
controversies of the 1990s
when during john major's administration
two ex-ministers
ended up in jail the parliamentary
inquiry means david cameron is likely to
be forced to give evidence
on camera his controversial relationship
with lex greenseal has led
to a wider look at lobbying reform of
the rules
seems inevitable joe pike sky news
westminster